WOULD YOU SWALLOW A MEDICAL IMPLANT IF IT
MEANT PROTECTING YOUR HEALTH?
PRETTY SOON, YOU CAN.
HEY THIS IS ANNIE FOR DNEWS.
WE KNOW THAT EVEN COMMON MEDICATIONS CAN HAVE
SIDE EFFECTS THAT AREN'T FUN...YOU KNOW, THE
ONES PHARMA COMPANIES SPIT OUT AT THE END
OF THEIR DRUG ADS AS QUICKLY AS HUMANLY POSSIBLE.
EXACERBATING THIS IS THE FACT THAT ABOUT HALF
OF PEOPLE TAKE MEDICATIONS INCORRECTLY ANYWAY,
ACCORDING TO A SURVEY BY THE WORLD HEALTH
ORGANIZATION.
SCIENTISTS ARE WORKING ON THIS PROBLEM THOUGH
IN THE FORM OF SMART MEDS OR EVEN IMPLANTS.
A TEAM FROM THE AMERICAN CHEMICAL SOCIETY
BUILT NANOSHEETS THAT COMBINED ANTI INFLAMMATORY
DRUGS WITH ELECTRODES THROUGH A POLYMER FILM.
THEY WERE THEN ABLE TO CONTROL THE RELEASE
OF THE DRUG THROUGH ELECTRICAL SHOCKS.
IT'S IN THE DEVELOPMENT STAGE, BUT THEY SAY
THIS TECHNIQUE COULD BE USEFUL IN TREATING
DISEASES LIKE EPILEPSY, WHERE A MEDICATION
IS ALREADY IN YOUR BODY AND CAN BE RELEASED
RIGHT AWAY AS A SEIZURE HAPPENS.
THIS STUDY IS JUST ONE OF MANY PROJECTS IN
THE WORKS TO CREATE PROGRAMMABLE MEDS.
FOR EXAMPLE, SWALLOWABLE MICROCHIPS HAVE ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED BY THE FDA.
A COMPANY CALLED PROTEUS DIGITAL CREATED MICROCHIP-EMBEDDED
PILLS WITH TINY SENSORS THAT CAN REACT TO
DIGESTIVE JUICES.
THAT RELAYS A SIGNAL TO A PATCH ON YOUR SKIN,
WHICH CAN THEN BE RELAYED TO YOUR DOCTOR.
SO IF SOMETHING'S AWRY, OR YOU'RE NOT TAKING
YOUR MEDS CORRECTLY, THEY CAN GET ALERTED
AUTOMATICALLY.
AND IN 2012, SCIENTISTS BUILT TINY NANOBOTS
OUT OF HUMAN DNA THAT CONTAIN GOOD ENZYMES....ACTING
KIND OF LIKE A TROJAN HORSE, THEY LOOK AND
ACT LIKE NORMAL HUMAN DNA BUT HOLD ON THOUGH
THESE ARE STILL IN THE DEVELOPMENT STAGE,
DOCTORS ARE HOPEFUL THAT THESE DNA TREATMENTS
CAN BE PROGRAMMED TO ATTACK CANCERS ON THE
MOLECULAR LEVEL.
AND THEN OF COURSE THERE ARE THOSE SMART CONTACT
LENSES RECENTLY ANNOUNCED BY GOOGLE, WHICH
ARE MEANT TRACK GLUCOSE LEVELS THROUGH YOUR
TEARS.
THERE ARE ACTUALLY A BUNCH OF COMPANIES WORKING
ON SIMILAR CONCEPTS AND FOR MORE ON THAT,
CHECK OUT MY VIDEO ON MY OTHER CHANNEL IF
YOU'RE INTERESTED...
SO WHETHER IT'S A LENS, A MINISCULE CLUSTER
OF DNA OR A SWALLOWABLE MICROCHIP...YOUR FUTURE
DOCTOR MIGHT BE...WELL, REALLY TINY.
WOULD YOU BE WILLING TO SWALLOW A PILL THAT
SENDS INFO TO YOUR DOCTOR?
LET US KNOW WHY OR WHY NOT IN THE COMMENTS,
AND AS ALWAYS YOU CAN TALK BACK TO THE SHOW
ON TWITTER AT DNEWS, OR THE DISCOVERY NEWS
FACEBOOK PAGE, OR TO ME DIRECTLY AT ANNIEGAUS.
THANKS FOR WATCHING!
SEE YOU NEXT TIME.